哈喽我是小三零
今天跟你分享我的战斗经验
我曾经是一个豆皮脚
九年的豆豆
全面能让我超过三千克豆豆
它不是额头
我的额头非常地容易长
避口和豆豆
那现在给你们看一下我素严
现在是我标击传惯夫
然后还没有参访上的皮膚
是不是还挺心力的
那接下来我就跟你分享
我是用了什么呢
那第一点就是身份清潔
我每周会做一到两次身份清潔
那身份清潔并不是说
用一个清潔面模就OK了
清潔面模是没有办法把你毛孔里的
髒东西都给你清出来的
那那些人髒东西你不管他清出来
他会就会躲在你的毛孔
让你外面的东西又进不去
里面的东西出过来
九二九支他就形成了闭口了
那对我多年那么总结了
一泡非常有用的
是曾经解大法
这方法呢
你没有愿意什么
海苗秀了大气泡小气泡
都要好用
自从我用了这个方法之后
我的毛孔
它就干净了了
是九十
而且我的黑头也检少了
咱们这九十
那你毛孔
一干净
它就会显得很小心
那你的皮膚非常的吸引你
它清潔一次可以让你的
肌膚味十好几天
都是干净的
这方法呢
它很经济时会
比美容愿办法要
麻烦多拉
你们可以关注我
之后我都会分享
在我的主店里面的
那第二点就是
你可以考虑
把酸类的产品
加入到你的日常
护服当中来
我之前都是会去皮膚
准备做
灌抚或者是做几光
那我做完了
之后是有效果的
但是没过几天
我的闭口又长出来了
那我的医生呢
它就会给我开你
种酸类的精华让我使用
我发现
它是给我开视上
我用几天
然后停几天
都发了我一
停几天
我就又会长立口
然后这想说呢
我是一项每天都用酸
怎么样呢
然后我就发现
照顾减出几的好
发酸
在加上身层清潔
就可以把我的
立口度觉得
就是九十
皮膚非常的光滑
健康
而且还变白了
点了门
你们不要一上
一上来就整个那种
大大梦的酸类的精华
这个就是你
一定要根据自己的皮膚
那一上情况来选择一个合适的酸
那我呢
就是用的是一个
六酸的精华
我用过
好多好多的酸啊
然后用下来之后
我发现
它是最适合我的
我每天都会用它
用的一滴
上在我的皮膚
脂肤掌制成的
掉后的去
放上起来
我用
你看
就是感觉
哦皮膚在发光
就这样子
不一定要跟我用一样的酸啊
我就是给你们
一个建议
就是在日常生活中
加一点酸
那第三点
我就想跟你们
想一个超级
去斗大宝放
就是这个
斗斗水
它应该是一个法国的品牌办
我是看博主
彭包子推荐
然后去买了
买了之后
我就好后回啊
我没有早一点去买它呢
它对于这种红种大豆
效果就是非常好
它不是说
治标啊
它是治本
你用了它
大概用你一段时间
就会发现你不长了
那种红种大豆
你就不长了
跟你就没关系了
如果是喜欢
莫名其妙长那种红种大豆的名声
你们可以试一下
它这个效果真的是
非常非常的厉害
那我发现它不只是
对于红种大豆
它对于那种黑头也很有作用
我用了它
超红的黑头就点熟好多好多
你们可以去试一下
这一平呢
它不便宜
它是50毫升式
我买来试用七百块钱
但是它非常非常的金融
我用了两个月了
把菜用到这里
我到往上看是有分装卖的
好像是10毫升台
一上百块钱吧
你们可以先去买分装试一下
那最后演呢
就是面商一定要非常的精爽
不要再使用那些
非常厚重的
师傅类的面商徒代臉上了
我们是豆子温不是敏感机
你越轰了你逼口就越多
可以使用这种质疊非常清爽的
看
敏怒质疊的这种面刷
都比非常地友好一点都不温度
那我的据到小明明已经非常完喽
你们打开试试来吧
记得来给我打块哦